Well guys, listen, do you feel the chill in the air? Do you feel the holiday spirit? I do. I feel the crackling of the fire. Oh, it's so nice, huh? Yeah. It's chilly outside. Nothing says a holiday.
大家听着，嘿，你们感觉得到空气中的寒意吗？感觉得到节日的气氛吗？我感觉得到。我能听到炉火的噼啪声。哦，太美妙了，对吧？是的。外面很冷。没有什么比这更能说明节日的气氛了。
It's like, oh, wait a second. We're not doing an ad. What are you doing? Like, yeah. This is just for smartness. Never go to the post office again. I think we're just doing a nice little holiday lead-in for this week's smartness.
就像是，哦，等一下。我们不是在做广告。你在干嘛？就像，对。这只是为了显得聪明。再也不用去邮局了。我想我们只是在为本周的聪明才智做一个很好的节日开场白。
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. Oh my God. Smart, wise, smart, wise. Jason, you look beautiful today. You look really smiley and you're wearing a nice colored shirt that must mean that you're going to the office. Is that is that yeah Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I got a bunch of work to do today. Yeah, the office you do. Yeah, where you got like a driver off the tee No, I don't take a drive. I just self-drive. I don't drive myself to work Your car you don't have a self-driving car. Here's the thing last night was really fun
达，哒，哒，哒……哦，天哪。聪明，明智，聪明，明智。杰森，你今天看起来真帅。你看上去满脸笑容，而且穿着一件颜色很好看的衬衫，那一定意味着你要去办公室。是这样的吗？是，是，是，是。是的，我今天有很多工作要做。是的，去办公室。你去做。是的，你在发球区有个发球手什么的？不，我不用发球手。我只是自动驾驶。我没有开车去上班。你的车？你没有自动驾驶汽车。事情是这样的，昨晚真的很有趣。
We all hung out. Yeah, we did and will was dabbing like crazy with the dab moves and then Jason Google's Google's dab because you didn't quite get it. No, hang on. Yeah, don't forget Jason held us one up and said hey Siri What does dab mean? Well, I want to know is it an acronym is it you know answered my phone just answered it was so And then what came up? one's father and I was that oh, she thought I said dad and then I said dab and And
我们都在一起玩。是的，我们去了，威尔疯狂地跳着dabbing舞，然后杰森用谷歌搜索了什么是dab，因为你不太懂。不，等等。没错。别忘了，杰森举起手机说，嘿，Siri，什么是dab？好吧，我想知道，这是一个缩写吗？它……你知道的。我的手机刚接通，就直接接通了，然后……然后弹出了什么？“父亲的……”然后我说，哦，她以为我说的是“老爸（dad）”，然后我说的是“dab”，然后……
Nothing, she didn't even she ignored me. No, and had you not in second and you've never seen someone dab before no I've seen the dab, but I want to know what you tell me. Yeah, I don't know. Don't get on my face about it I don't know what it is History of the dab or maybe Tracy knows Tracy might well Tracy knows she lives in Wisconsin She would know what that means dab capital of the world and then Jay and then Jay went on a little like side side thing where he was like Should I wear overalls? Do you want to know why overalls aren't aren't popular anymore? Yeah, I wore them a lot when I was 12 13 14 15 I mean, I thought they were that was fashion back then and now like there's you know
什么也没有，她甚至连理都没理我。不，而且你以前从没见过别人跳dab舞吗？没有，我见过dab舞，但我想知道……你告诉我。好吧，我不知道。别冲着我发火，我不知道那是什么。Dab的历史，或者也许特雷西知道。特雷西很可能知道，她住在威斯康星州。她会知道那是什么意思，那是Dab的世界之都。然后杰森又扯到了一边，他说：我是不是该穿背带裤？你们想知道为什么背带裤不再流行了吗？是的，我12、13、14、15岁的时候经常穿。我的意思是，我当时觉得那是时尚，而现在，你看……
Like the Beastie boys have like the boiler suits, you know those little onesies or like like prison prison onesies I'd like to wear that like to just zip into something and just get out the door because it's easy. Yeah But what do you so what are you waiting for just bring them back? You'll be the one to bring I don't have that kind of I don't have that kind of style status where I can just you know Make something happen Jason's nervous that he'd be judged if I'm being if we can be honest He wouldn't want to be judged in that way so much that I don't I just don't want to be distracted by people yelling at me saying Hey loser get off the street, you know He's gonna you don't have to wear overalls here that attention to what you're doing
就像野兽男孩（Beastie boys）穿的那种锅炉工连体裤，你知道那种连体衣，或者像监狱犯人的那种连体囚服。我也想穿成那样，就想拉上拉链就能出门，因为那样很方便。对。那你还等什么，把它带回来啊？你会成为那个……我没有那种风格地位，我做不到那种事。杰森很紧张，如果说实话的话，他会觉得自己会被评判。他非常不想用那种方式被评判，以至于我不想……我只是不想被那些对我有意见、对我大喊大叫的人分心，他们会说：嘿，失败者，离开这条街，你知道的……你在这里不用穿背带裤，那种关注度……
Yeah, I could give two fucks what you're doing. Listen. Let me say this. Yeah, I suggested That I want to go back to doing wearing overalls with no shirt sort of Dexys midnight runner style. I can't do that I don't why and then I and then just dance around on a street corner. Yeah Come on Okay Will's will's got new new earphones on Whatever they're called. What's uh, did you go little monitor? Oh, yeah, you don't have your big things on my little monitors I'm just trying for those. What do you think?
是的，我对你在做什么一点兴趣也没有。听着。让我这么说吧。是的，我建议过，我想重新开始穿那种不穿衬衫的背带裤，有点像Dexys Midnight Runners乐队的风格。我做不到。我不知道为什么。然后我就在街角跳舞。好吧，威尔戴上了新的耳机……无论它们叫什么。什么……你是用那种小监听耳机吗？哦，对，你没有戴那个大耳机。我用的小监听耳机，我正在试用这个。你觉得怎么样？
I bet you didn't I can't I can't confirm or deny anything right now But it looks like they might be molded for your ears because your professional voice over look at that What do you think about them? They're pretty good Yeah, they're pretty good and they keep they keep the the things away from your hair Well, here's the thing if you really want to know so the can so cans what you guys are wearing it what I usually use and have worn for Years and Everybody does it's very traditional like this. Yeah, as you know You wear them they're fine to wear for a little while if you're recording if I'm doing some spots for GMC, which is a superior vehicle
我敢打赌你……我现在不能证实或否认任何事，但看起来它们可能是为你定制的耳朵形状，因为你有专业的配音员……看看那个。你觉得它们怎么样？它们挺好的。是的，它们挺好的，而且它们能让那些东西离你的头发远一点。好吧，事情是这样的，如果你真的想知道的话，那么——大耳机，就是你们戴的那种，也是我多年来一直在用、每个人都在用的那种——非常传统，就像这样。是的，正如你所知，你戴着它们，如果只是录一小会儿音的话还好，如果我要为GMC录制一些广告插播——这是一款卓越的汽车……
Especially the new GMC sear AT4x. Okay, GMC sear Wait, wait, what's the new what's the new catch phrase you've got it's sophisticated, but strong something like that. Well, it's about It's a big speaking of sophisticated and strong. Let's get to our guest because he's waiting Wow He's waiting. Don't cut off will with his great story about the the progression of they get hot is my point That's enough. We got it. Sean. Let's hear the guest Okay, okay guys, I'm super excited By the way, you like bring up a subject and I agree with it and then you you're like, why are you talking about that stupid thing? You fall into our humiliated me the other day without about
尤其是全新的GMC Sierra AT4x。好吧，GMC Sierra……等等，等等，你那个新口号是什么来着？“既优雅又强劲”，诸如此类的话。好吧，说到优雅和强劲，让我们请出我们的嘉宾，因为他已经在等了。哇，他在等。别打断威尔，他刚才在讲那个关于它们会发热的精彩故事……够了，我们知道了。肖恩，让我们听听嘉宾怎么说。好吧，好吧，各位，我超级兴奋。顺便说一句，你提起一个话题，我表示赞同，然后你又会说：你为什么要在谈论那种蠢事？你昨天还当众羞辱了我……
Anyway, sorry, here we go this person today one more time He's an he's an amazing human being an incredible actor one of the best actors of our lifetime truly Everybody loves this guy. I've had the immense pleasure of working in many times over the years He's won an Emmy. He's been nominated for three Academy Awards, and he doesn't know it, but I watch him Every single night on reruns of Cheers. It's Woody Harrelson. Woody. Hello. Oh How did you enjoy waiting that long I really enjoyed it. I didn't even want to come on I was like I was trying to keep myself from laughing, but I was laughing. He took a quick nap How did Sean how did Sean beat me and will to getting you on this show? I know we work together
不管怎样，抱歉，我们开始吧。今天这位嘉宾，再重复一遍，他是一个了不起的人，一个不可思议的演员，是我们这个时代最伟大的演员之一，真的。每个人都爱这家伙。多年来，我有幸与他合作过很多次。他得过艾美奖。他获得过三项奥斯卡金像奖提名，而且他自己都不知道，我每天晚上都在看《干杯酒吧》（Cheers）的重播。他就是伍迪·哈里森（Woody Harrelson）。伍迪。你好。哦，你等了这么久，感觉怎么样？我真的挺享受的。我甚至都不想出场了，我一直在极力忍住不笑，但我还是笑出来了。他刚才小睡了一会儿。肖恩是怎么做到比我和威尔更快把你请到这个节目来的？我知道我们过去合作过……
Back in the day because we mean when you're tight, you know, you are you are surprisingly tight with a lot of folks Sean I know I think I know is everybody what did you Woody? What did you and Sean work on together? We worked on Cheers where I was at up Well, I'm great. I'm sorry. I'm willing great. We're gonna willing grace and then we did that live sitcom together where he played Archie Bunker and I played the neighbor. Oh, no way. Okay. Well, why don't we let him answer that? I asked what is the guest? Well, just in case you didn't remember Well, also also Woody I was at a party at your house years and years ago where I made out with Alicia Silverstone When she she she's one of the sweetest people I was she knew I was gay
在过去的日子里，因为我的意思是，当你关系很铁的时候，你知道，你和很多人关系都出奇地好，肖恩。我知道，我想我知道每个人……伍迪，你和肖恩一起合作过什么？我们在《干杯酒吧》里合作过，当时我在上……哦，我很棒，抱歉，我和威尔……我们在《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will & Grace）里合作过，然后我们一起演了那个直播情景喜剧，他在里面扮演阿奇·邦克（Archie Bunker），我扮演邻居。哦，不会吧。好吧，为什么不让他来回答呢？我问嘉宾是谁……好吧，以防你不记得了。好吧，还有，伍迪，许多年前我在你家的一场派对上和阿利西亚·西尔维斯特龙（Alicia Silverstone）接过吻。当她……她是最甜美的人之一，她知道我是个同性恋……
It was like no big deal, but you're just being silly Wait, what? Yeah, hang on. Yeah, sorry what it would be you in one second Sean walk me through walk me through with that what that negotiation was like. Hey, Elise. Oh, we were children We were children. How old is that? Like early 20s. Okay, and she you said to her not that she needed to hear it that you are gay But that you forgotten what it's like to kiss a girl's mouth and and and you asked her You asked her, would you like to kiss a gay man's mouth? Let's get let's We were being silly we were
这没什么大不了的，但你只是在耍宝。等等，什么？是的，等等。是的，抱歉，伍迪，等一下。肖恩，给我讲讲，给我讲讲当时的谈判是怎么样的。嘿，爱丽丝……我们当时还是孩子。我们还是孩子。当时多大？大概20岁出头吧。好吧，然后你对她说——倒不是她需要听到这个——说你是同性恋，但你已经忘记亲吻女孩的嘴唇是什么感觉了，然后你问她……你问她：“你想亲吻一个同性恋男人的嘴唇吗？”让我们回到……我们当时在开玩笑，我们……
Drinking we were young we were drinking and it was Woody Harrelson's house and it was fun. That was a party Wow, what do you what do we find you of today? You look like you're in a beach community. No, I'm in a Winnipeg. It's a beautiful day in Winnipeg. Here comes the Canadian wait a second Wait a second way to say woody my whole family both sides of my family are from Winnipeg. Really? Yeah, okay Is there anyone you want me to look up? Yeah. Yes Quick, what are their names? Well, what do you ask them what their names are? Yeah, what are their names? Yeah, he has no idea. Well, that's not true. I got my cousin Sally and my cousin Joanie and And uh, you're making all this up and talking great aunt. No, no, no go visit my great aunt. Uh, you know
我们在喝酒，我们还年轻，我们在喝酒，那是伍迪·哈里森的家，很有趣。那真是一场派对。哇，伍迪，我们今天在哪里能找到你？你看起来像是在一个海滨社区。不，我在温尼伯。温尼伯今天天气真好。加拿大人来了，等一下，等一下，好样的，伍迪。我的整个家族，我父母双方的家族都来自温尼伯。真的吗？好吧，有什么人需要我去查查看吗？是的。快点，他们叫什么名字？好吧，伍迪，问问他们叫什么名字。是的，他们叫什么名字？是的，他根本不知道。好吧，那不是真的。我有我的表妹莎莉和表妹乔妮，还有……你在瞎编，还说什么伟大的姑妈……不，不，不，去拜访我的伟大的姑妈……你知道的……
Any in any am no, we're not doing anti and Wizard of Oz polls here Um, what are you doing at Winnipeg? Um, I'm doing this movie called champions. Uh, bobby fairleys directing. Oh great. Yeah Now is it uh, is it one of his, uh Uh newer films that are more dramatic uh in tone or is are we back to uh semen in the hair? That was the original time it didn't clear someone had it already so they went with something about mary. Um, this is a comedy This is a comedy. Oh good. Yeah
什么安妮、安妮的，我们这里可不是在搞《绿野仙踪》的选角。嗯，你在温尼伯做什么？嗯，我在拍一部叫《冠军》（Champions）的电影。鲍比·法雷利（Bobby Farrelly）导演的。哦，太棒了。是的。现在，这是一部……这是他语气更偏向戏剧化的新电影之一吗？还是说我们又回到了头发里有精液的桥段？那是最初的片名，但还没通过，因为已经有人用了，所以他们选了关于玛丽的那个片名。嗯，这是一部喜剧。这是一部喜剧。哦，太好了。是的。
Are you all done with um with uh, Justin Thoreau? Yeah. Yeah, we finished that six months. We did that Good lord. Yeah, that was crazy because of covid stuff. Is that why it took so long or was it a was it a bunch of episodes? Well, there was a couple of uh shutdowns actually Yeah, was that due to Thoreau's lack of sleeves? Did that enter into it? Was that part of the Yeah, why they had to shut it down the sleeve local come over and shut you down Uh, listen or this we're talking about a watergate. Uh, a watergate, uh show that woody did with Justin Uh for hpo. I think it should be pretty funny. Yeah, white house plumbers. Yeah, I'm very looking for that Oh, it's gonna be great. I I gotta say Justin really knocked it out of the park and uh, must have been a pretty small park
你们拍完……跟……贾斯汀·塞洛克斯（Justin Theroux）合作完了吗？是的，是的，我们在六个月前完成了。我们拍完了。天哪。是的，因为新冠疫情的原因，太疯狂了。这就是花了这么长时间的原因吗？还是因为有大量集数？嗯，实际上有几次停拍。是的，这是因为塞洛克斯没有穿袖子衣服吗？这有影响吗？这是……他们不得不停拍的原因吗？袖子当地管理局过来勒令你们停工……听着，或者这个……我们在谈论水门事件……一个由伍迪和贾斯汀为HBO合作的水门事件剧集。我觉得应该挺搞笑的。是的，《白宫 plumbers》（White House Plumbers）。是的，我非常期待这个。哦，这会很棒的。我得说，贾斯汀真的干得非常出色，而且……那一定是个很小的公园吧。
Dog park Wait, wait, wait, wait, woody. Let me ask you this. I've always wanted to know this about uh, first of all, great to see you man I'm so happy you're here I wanted to get you on this thing so bad, too. And then um, so you started your first big thing was cheers obviously you came on after coach I forget the actor's name. He was really terrific. Yeah, Nicholas calisanto
狗公园。等等，等等，等等，伍迪。让我问你这个：我一直想知道关于……首先，很高兴见到你，老兄。我太高兴你来了。我太想把你请到这个节目里来了。然后，嗯……你开始的第一件大事显然是《干杯酒吧》，你在教练（Coach）之后加入了剧组，我忘了那个演员的名字了。他真的很棒。是的，尼古拉斯·科拉斯桑托（Nicholas Colasanto）。
Yeah, Nicholas calisanto, but you came in and it was like big shoes to fill and you came in woody man And you were shot out of a cannon episode. It felt like you had been on the show forever drilled it. You were great I loved you on the show. I mean, there's so many I still to this day do Kelly Kelly Kelly Kelly ke l l y I mean, I fucking love it. How did Cheers come about how did it come into your orbit? How did you audition for what? Yeah What what was that experience like started to go way back? But we have to go back to and just to tag on to that woody before you answer that
是的，尼古拉斯·科拉斯桑托，但你加入了，那可是个很难填补的空缺，而你加入了，伍迪，老兄。你就像一颗被大炮发射出来的炮弹一样。感觉你好像已经在剧集里待了永远那么久。你完美驾驭了。你太棒了。我太喜欢你在剧里的表现了。我的意思是，有那么多……我至今仍然会说：凯利，凯利，凯利，凯利，凯——利。我的意思是，我他妈太爱了。你是怎么加入《干杯酒吧》的？你是怎么进入这个圈子的？你是怎么去试镜的？那段经历是怎样的？这要追溯到很久以前了。但我们必须回到……为了接上这个话题，伍迪，在你回答之前……
I I didn't know this until I was researching some of the stuff that you're from Hanover So will's question about how did it start and how did you get it and also the Hanover woody? Obviously, they took your name and they took your hometown too. Was that your idea their idea? Well, the character was already called woody boy But and the character was from indiana. I'm not from there, but I went to college at Hanover So I did ask him to use that but uh, you know to answer your question. I was uh I got a little break from this show. I was doing or I was an understudy in this
我直到在研究你的一些资料时才知道你是从汉诺威（Hanover）来的。所以威尔问你是怎么开始的、你是怎么得到这个角色的，还有汉诺威，伍迪。显然，他们不仅用了你的名字，还用了你的家乡。那是你的主意还是他们的主意？嗯，这个角色本来就叫伍迪·博伊德（Woody Boyd），而且这个角色来自印第安纳州。我不是那里的人，但我在汉诺威上过大学。所以我确实要求他们使用这个设定，但是……你知道，回答你的问题，我当时……我从我正在出演的一部剧里得到了一个小假期，或者说我是在……中担任替补演员……
Neil Simon Biloxi blues and So I got a little break to go do a movie with Goldie Hawn and and then as I was wrapping up They fired the two guys. I was understudying. So I was going to get to go on stage, which is that was my dream. I was 23 I was 23. Anyway, this buddy of mine Leo Jeter in LA. I run into him and you know, my agent hadn't said anything But he says, you know, there's this part on the show called cheers that you should look into, you know Wow, I was like, well, he says the guy's from indiana. His name's woody That's so crazy. And had you seen the show before wait wait, no way And the agent commissioned 10% for how many years? Yeah. Yeah for doing, uh
尼尔·西蒙（Neil Simon）的《比洛克西蓝调》（Biloxi Blues）。所以我得到了一小段假期去和戈尔迪·霍恩（Goldie Hawn）拍一部电影。然后，就在我快要拍完时，他们把我要替补的那两个家伙给解雇了。所以我本来可以上台表演了，那可是我的梦想。我当时23岁。我当时23岁。不管怎样，我在洛杉矶遇到了我的一个朋友利奥·杰特（Leo Jeter）。我碰到了他，你知道的，我的经纪人什么都没说，但他说，你知道，剧里有个叫《干杯酒吧》的角色，你应该去了解一下，你知道的。哇，我当时想，好吧，他说那家伙来自印第安纳州，名叫伍迪。太疯狂了。你以前看过这部剧吗？等等，等等，不会吧。经纪人为这个抽成了10%，持续了多少年？对，对，为了出演……
Yeah, but yeah, no, but anyway, so I was at the time. I was really into this idea I'll just do theater. I will not be You know doing television, but then I watched it and I was like, oh man, this is uh pretty good Yeah, yeah, and was it was it a hit? I knew it took a while to become a hit But was it a hit when you joined? Well, it had been on for three years. It was a hit But it did it then it kept going, you know kept Yeah, when you did the thing the the archibunker thing, was it nice to get back into that
是的，但是……不管怎样，所以当时我真的迷上了这种想法：我只想演戏剧。我绝不会去演电视剧。但后来我看了一下，然后我想，哦，天哪，这挺不错的。是的，是的，它是一部热门剧吗？我知道它花了一段时间才成为热门剧，但当你加入时它已经是热门剧了吗？嗯，它已经播出了三年了。它是一部热门剧，但后来它一直在继续，你知道的，一直在……是的，当你做那个……那个阿奇·邦克的事情时，重新回到那种节奏、那种日程安排中、回到那种情景喜剧中，跟吉米·伯罗斯（Jimmy Burrows）以及所有人一起，感觉好吗？它带回了许多回忆吗？那不是很搞笑吗？是的，是的，那真的很酷。我以前没机会和吉米合作，你知道的，肖恩。我的意思是，他妈的，是的，那太棒了。但我当时有点害怕，你知道的，只是……阿奇·邦克，你知道的。哦，你太棒了。你太棒了。哦，谢谢。你太厉害了。是的，完美。你从不失手。你从不失手。你知道的，就像……我想，我想，我想公众和这个行业可能觉得他们已经把你定型、归类了五六次，而不可避免地，你的下一部作品是：等等，他在演什么？他演的是个什么角色？然后你看着看着，就会想：天哪，我从不知道伍迪还有那一面。我的意思是，真的没有什么事是你做不到的。
Into that rhythm into that schedule again into that, uh, the sitcom stuff and with jimmy burrows and all that Did it bring back a bunch of memories? Isn't that fun? Yeah. Yeah, that was really cool I I didn't get into work with jimmy, you know, shon. I mean fuck. Yeah, that was awesome. Uh, but I was a little scared, you know, just Archibunker, you know, oh you were so great. You were so great. Oh, thanks. You were so good. Yeah, perfect You're never bad. You're never bad and you know, like I think I think I think the public and maybe the industry probably thought They've had you pegged and pigeonholed probably five or six times and and inevitably your next job is like Wait, he's in what and he's playing what character and then you watch it and you're like Jesus I never knew woody had that side. I mean, there's just nothing you can't do
确实如此。我记得我看到你……正如杰森所说，你在你的演艺生涯中不时地冒出来。然后当我看到你演的《天生杀人狂》（Natural Born Killers）时，我在想：等等，那是《干杯酒吧》里的伍迪·哈里森吗？《天生杀人狂》……那是我见过的最棒的表演之一，你只是……太不可思议了，就像杰森刚刚说的，你做的一切都太棒了。我的意思是，继续说……《逃出熔炉》（Out of the Furnace）。简直好得疯狂。接连不断，没完没了。所以，跟我聊聊《天生杀人狂》，以及与奥利弗·斯通（Oliver Stone）合作是怎样的感受，因为我确信你有一些疯狂的时刻或故事。
It truly and I remember seeing you to Jason's point you pop up here and there in your career And then when I saw you natural born killers, I was like, wait, that's woody harrelson from cheers and natural born killer And that was one of the best performances I'd ever seen you just it was incredible everything like Jason just said everything you do is It's amazing. I mean keep going me out of the furnace. It's just like crazy good Just on and on and on so tell me about natural born killers and what it was like working with Oliver stone because I'm sure you have some insane moments or stories Oh, there were some insane moments for sure, but uh, no, I I liked working with him. He can be a little uh You guys ever hung out with him? You must have never you know, he tries to stir shit up all the time really
哦，确实有一些疯狂的时刻，但是……不，我喜欢跟他合作。他有时会有点……你们跟他在一块儿混过吗？你们一定没有，你知道的，他总是试图挑起事端，真的。但我可以举个例子。有一次，有一个场景是，在一家药店外面有所有这些窗户，这些警察把我困在药店里面，他们要……所以所有的窗户都被他们朝药店里开枪给打碎了，我应该跑出去做这做那的……所以有巨大无比的窗户，而且这三个超级大的窗户全都被炸碎了，奥利弗在开拍前走到我面前说：“这是一个半小时的重置。别搞砸了。开拍。”
But like I'll give you an example like one time There's this scene where there's like there's all these windows outside of this pharmacy that are these cops have me trapped Inside this pharmacy and they're gonna so all the windows get blown out from them shooting at me in the pharmacy and I'm supposed to run and do whatever and uh, so there's huge giant windows Uh, and and it's all three of these mega windows getting blown out and Oliver comes to me just before the take and goes uh Uh, uh, this is an hour and a half reset. Don't fuck it up rolling
谢谢你的爱抚，老兄。哦，天哪。但你成功驾驭了。完美驾驭。你知道我刚才说的那个……那种纪律上的切换开关吗？我认为每个人在做事时都有一个要触及的点。当你……当你……当你做事时，你给人的感觉就像是……你知道的，生活中很多事情都很随性。你不会被很多有压力的事所困扰。但你肯定有这样一面：你知道如何拨动那个开关，在需要的时候成为一个刺客，无论是对工作的严谨准备，还是在当场按下开关并完美呈现。
Thanks for the pet dog Oh, jeez, but you nailed it nailed it You know what I mean about that that whole sort of that that discipline toggle switch I think everyone has got a hit, you know, when you're when you're when you're doing stuff Um, you you come across as someone who just kind of you know, it's real casual about a lot of things in life You don't get hung up on a lot of stressful stuff But there's got to be a side of you that knows how to flick that switch and just be an assassin when you need to whether it be Just discipline on preparing for work or at the moment
你有没有这样一面——这一面你平时不怎么向我们展示，但它是你的……你的私人秘密武器，能让你真正收敛心神并雷厉风行地执行？没有，没有，一切都很随性。不，杰森，你需要知道的是，杰森，像伍迪和我这样的人，这一切都是自然而然流露出来的。我们只是他妈的……我们不会去想。我们不去想，我们不是预谋好的，老兄。就像你，伍迪和我，我们只是在不同的层面上运作。抱歉，抱歉。威尔，顺便说一句……
hitting the switch and delivering Is there a side to you that is a side that you you don't really show a lot of us But is sort of your your your private sort of secret weapon where you can really get small and uh an execute No, no, it's all casual No Jason you what you need to know Jason is that guys like Woody and me it just comes to us organically It's we just fucking we don't think about it. We don't think we don't we're not premeditated, dude Like you Woody and I are just operating on a different plane. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Well, by the way
我……我在相当多的作品里见过你，然后我在看《早间新闻》（The Morning Show），接着你突然出现在《早间新闻》里。你的开销很高。你只是……你在做所有事情。你的开销很大。我只是想……我只是想让人们质疑他们对我的看法，你知道我的意思吗？就像，我只是想让他们一直在猜，伍迪。我在以比你更小的规模做这件事，现在我准备把它带到下一个level了。好吧，我们在猜，我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。伍迪和我……我几乎记不清了，所以我知道，伍迪，你可能也记不清了，因为你是……你是……你是比我年长吗？我52岁。你多大？是的，我比你大，老兄。还记得我刚认识你的时候，你大概17岁吗？
I've I've seen you in quite a number of things and And then I'm like watching the morning show and then you pop up in the morning show He's got a high overhead. You're just what you're doing everything. You got a lot of overhead I'm just trying to I'm just trying to make people question what they think about me You know what I mean? Like I just want to keep him guessing Woody I'm doing it on a smaller scale than you've been doing and now I'm ready to take it to the next level Well, we're guessing and we will be right back And now back to the show Woody and I have uh that I can barely remember so I know Woody
没错，我们有一段历史。所以，是的，伍迪和我，我们第一次见面是不是在……参加赛车比赛的时候？哦，不，我想我之前就见过你，你知道的，因为我经常在派拉蒙和迈克混在一起，是的，我可能在那之前就见过你。但我们在那里……真的开始彼此了解，是在那个……是的。所以，贾斯蒂娜（Justine）和我参加了这场赛车比赛，一场丰田长滩大奖赛名流赛，伍迪也参加了，然后……你当时表现怎么样？
You probably can't remember because you're are you are you are you older than I am? I'm 52. How old are you? Yes, I'm older than you dude. Remember when I met you you were like 17 Right, we've got some history. So yeah, Woody and I think did we first meet doing the uh doing the car race? Well, no, I I think I met you before that, you know, because I was so overhanging out With Mike and Paramount and yeah, I might have met you before that But that's where we really, you know started to get to know each other was in that Yeah, so Justina and I do this car race this celebrity car race Toyota Grand Prix along beach that Woody was in as well and um How'd you do it?
嗯，我……我表现得很好。我想我赢了那场比赛。你赢了。对，对，对。所以我们在训练。而且当时他们显然不查可卡因，那是……所以我们在训练，我们在威洛斯普林斯（Willow Springs）训练，伍迪和我开着同样颜色的车，伍迪……伍迪在一次高速转弯时把两边的车轮开进了泥地里，所以他冲过赛道，像翻了14个跟头一样，他的车被撞得支离破碎，整个后半部分都被撞掉了，车身倒扣着，停在……哦，天哪，停在赛道边上。我们所有人的车都从它旁边开过去，因为你知道的，他在我们前面，而且他车身倒扣着，到处都是烟，你可以看到他倒挂在驾驶座上，从他的五点式安全带上悬挂着，因为整辆车的后半部分都被撞掉了。而且我们开的是同样颜色的车，贾斯廷以为那是我。所以她把车停在路边。她……她吓坏了，她又叫又哭，然后我开车赶到，我说：“哦，天哪，那是谁？那是伍迪吗？”她就像：“哦，天哪，你还活着！哦，天哪，那是伍迪！”所以我们都去试图帮他出来，诸如此类的事情。那真的是……那是一个吓人的时刻，我记得你手只断了一小块骨头，是这样吗？
Uh, I did I did well. I think I won that one. You won that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, so we were training And they didn't obviously they didn't test for cocaine back then that it was So we were so we're training we're training at uh Well willow springs and woody and I are driving the same color car and woody woody drops a couple of wheels over into the dirt On a real high speed turn so he gets across the track and does like 14 cart wheels and his cars ripped apart like the whole back end whole back half was ripped off And it's upside down and it's resting in the in the in the oh my god On the side of the track and all of us cars come driving by it because you know, he's ahead of us
是的，我手断了两根骨头，然后……有几颗牙齿被……没有碎，但是……是的，非常幸运，因为……每个看到的人都说他们以为这是个致命事故，因为我从……好吧，你知道的，那是那种……我看了看我的……速度表，我不该这么做的。我记得9号弯，杰森。是的，那是全速的。是的，你可以在9号弯全速通过。我低头看了看我的速度表，上面写着105，然后，天哪，当我重新抬起头时，我刚刚偏离赛道一点点，然后当然我过度矫正了，导致汽车滑行了一会儿，然后——呼——直接飞出去了，并在落地前滑行了40英尺，因为那些家伙去检查了前灯、尾灯和所有东西，之后翻了六个半滚翻……而且，是的，天哪，我经历了整套“看到白光”的流程。真的吗？太不可思议了。那……那有没有阻止你继续赛车？
And he's upside down the smoke everywhere and you can see him hanging upside down In his driver's chair hanging from his five point harness Because the whole back half of the car had been ripped off and he's in the same color cars And justine thinks it's me. So she pulls over her car. She's all she's freaked out She's screaming and crying and then I come driving up. I'm like, oh my god. Who is that? Is that woody? She's like, oh my god, you're alive. Oh my god. It's woody So should we all go and try to help them and get out and all that stuff that was that yeah, that was a real Uh, that was a scary moment and I remember you only broke a little a little bone in your hand. Is that right?
不，他不知道，那只是训练。我们几周后继续去参加了比赛。然后他在比赛中又撞了，当然。好吧，你现在还赛车吗，伍迪？都是因为可卡因……不，我知道，对吧？在那之后我就戒了。是的，天哪，我紧随你其后。哦，然后伍迪和我开始了我们的危险冒险，大概是什么时候？一年后在纽约市？我们决定在深夜很晚的时候在街上闲逛，我和几个哥们儿都喝高了，你知道那些堆在人行道上的垃圾堆吗？所有那些被放到人行道上的垃圾袋，它们堆成了很大一堆垃圾袋，大概有20个。我觉得做个跳水比赛跳进这些垃圾袋里会很有趣，像翻转比赛一样。你还记得吗，伍迪？我没记错吧？我们像那样做空翻和侧手翻，然后落进袋子里。是的，是的，你当时太疯狂了，老兄。你真的是……我在那之后不久就失去了特权，但你坚持下来了，不过我们做到了。我们做到了。我们依然在谋生。是的，我们依然……干得好，我们。好吧，所以……
Yeah, I broke two bones in my hand And uh, a couple of teeth got uh, no cracked But yeah, pretty lucky because uh, everybody Saw it said they thought it was a fatality because I did I from well, you know, it's one of those were I looked at my Uh, spedometer, which you should I shouldn't have done I remember turn nine there Jason. Yeah, it's flat out. Yeah, you could go flat out on turn nine And I looked down at my speedometer and said 105 And then my god when I look back up
伍迪，在我看来，你就像那种……永远不会停止工作的家伙。我的意思是，顺便问一句，你出演了《游侠索罗》（Solo），那是我最喜欢的电影之一，星战电影《游侠索罗》。谢谢你。嗯，你似乎一直在工作，从来没有停过。你热爱这样吗？你会不会想：哦，天哪，我需要休息一下？看起来你好像从不休息，因为你仍然热爱它。嗯，你知道，这是个好问题，因为……我已经从四月份开始就没回过家了。想象一下，从四月份开始就没回过家。哇。你会以为没有什么比工作更能让我快乐的了，但老实说，我是一个非常懒散的嬉皮士，不知怎么的就陷入了这种困境，一旦我挺过这个……你知道的，一旦到了圣诞节，我肯定要请假休息一段时间。
I'd just gone think just a little bit off the track and then of course I over compensated which caused the car to skid for a moment and then whoosh just launched and um But 40 feet before landing because the guys went and looked at the headlights tail lights and everything did six and a half windows Uh after that and uh, yeah, god, I did the whole white light thing. Really? It was incredible and and and did that did that keep you from racing it? No, he didn't know that was just training We went on and did the race like a few weeks later
那现在哪里才是家呢？是哥斯达黎加吗？不，我从哥斯达黎加搬走了。我住在毛伊岛（Maui）。哦，那太棒了。是的，那太好了。哦，太棒了。嗯，我确实……我有一个听众的问题，一个来自纽约市名叫贾斯汀·T（Justin T）的听众……哦，你好。你可能和他合作过，也可能没有。我一直在和他聊天。他有一个问题想问你……这是……这简直是……我不知道我们还会接受听众的提问。这是来自一个名叫贾斯汀·T的随机听众。哦，天哪。所以……他想知道，你以热爱和滥用大麻以及其他致幻物质而闻名……这是他的原话。你的……你以热爱和滥用大麻以及其他致幻物质而闻名。工作有没有妨碍过你的毒瘾问题？等等，随之而来的问题是：你的毒瘾问题有没有因为工作而受到影响？谢谢你，来电者，贾斯汀·T。这是一个非常……深刻的问题。
And then he crashed in the race, of course Well, do you still race Woody? It's all the coke No, I know right that I got over it after that. Yeah, my god I was shortly behind you. Oh, and then Woody and I picked up our dangerous escapades That probably what was it a year later in New York City? We decided we were hanging out late late late at night walking around the streets of the couple of buddies of mine All banged up and you know all those piles of trash all the trash bags that get put out on the sidewalk They just they're like create these big large lumps of trash bags like 20 of them
事实上……它有时确实会妨碍到，因为……比如我醒来后想抽大麻（wake and bake），我会想：我不能抽大麻，我他妈不能抽大麻，得等到吃午饭。谢谢你问这个问题。我真不敢相信他竟然有时间问那个问题……把那个问题写下来。仅仅因为你知道的，他通常只是在躲避狗仔队，那是他的头号工作。所以他有时间把这个写下来，上帝保佑。不，但说真的，你有没有完全嗨大了去工作过？比如在《干杯酒吧》或者别的什么里，你在一个场景里，心想：我这是在哪儿？哦，是的，我……我在拍《干杯酒吧》，你知道的，我们已经拍了一段时间了……所以，不知道好几年了……然后我……嗯，我以为我们拍完了，我就上楼去和乔治·温特（George Wendt）一起抽了一根烟。然后我听到对讲机里传来：“伍迪，下来拍你的独白和C场戏。”然后我就想：哦……然后我下去了。结果就像：第一条，灾难；第二条，更糟，你知道的，拍了10条才过，吉米说：“伍迪，一切都好吗？”“是的，一切都好，吉米，一切都好。是的，我们再试一次。”
I thought it'd be fun to do like a Diving contest into these trash bags like a flip contest. Do you remember that Woody? Am I remember this correctly? We do like flips and cartwheels into it and land into the bags Yeah, yeah, you were you were wild, dude. You were actually I lost my privileges Shortly after that, but you got it together, but we made it. We made it. We're still making a living. Yeah, we're still good for us okay so
你知道的，所以原本很简单的一场戏，本来只需要花他妈的10条就能拍完，结果却成了一场灾难。所以我吸取了教训，我不能……所有你理所当然的事情都会烟消云散。我的意思是，你们俩，威尔和杰森，我敢肯定在拍摄时也吸过可卡因，你知道的，那根本不管用。杰森，那一点也不好玩。我做过一次，我花了一整天的时间试图让自己看起来不像是嗑大了。是的，我记得我们去年问过塞斯·罗根（Seth Rogan）。我们当时问他，老兄，你有没有……肖恩，你问过他：你有没有在工作前嗨过？他说他从来没有在没嗨的情况下工作过。
Woody It seems to me like you're one of those guys who Just doesn't stop working. I mean you're by the way, you're in uh, you're in solo, which is one of my favorite movies ever the Star Wars movie solo. Thank you. Um, you seem to you seem to constantly work never ever stop Do you love that you wish like oh god? I need a break It doesn't seem like you ever take a break because you still love it Well, you know, that's a good question because like I haven't been home since april imagine not being home since april Wow, and you would think that I love nothing more than to work
太疯狂了。我知道，是吗？是的。是的，他是这么说的。我听说克里斯托弗·沃肯（Christopher Walken）在公园里演莎士比亚之前也会嗨大。哦，天哪。如果你迷失了，你怎么开始用意境韵律诗进行即兴创作？那怎么行？哇。我知道，太疯狂了。你怎么能找回状态？但我想老一辈的演员们，所有那些老莎士比亚演员们，那些家伙过去常常会……你知道的，在英国那边，那些家伙过去常常会搞点刺激的……哦，是的，但我觉得那可能和吸大麻不同。对我来说，大麻……要想记住台词会很难，我可能会太容易分心了。我知道，对我来说，这更像是回家然后关机放松。那软糖（gummy）呢，杰森？你能吃着软糖工作吗？我可能行，只是因为……它进入血液系统的速度慢一点，它不会像大麻烟卷或烟斗那样直接猛击你的脖子，你知道的。
But honestly, I'm uh, I'm a very lazy hippie who somehow just got himself in this predicament And once I get through this, you know, once I make it to christmas. I'm taking some time off for sure And then where's home nowadays? Is it Costa Rica? No, I I moved from Costa Rica. I live in Maui Okay, that's great. Yeah. All right. Oh, that's awesome Um, I do have I do have a question from from a listener a listener in new york city named justin t Oh, hello that you may or may not have worked with He I was chatting with him He has a question for you. Uh, you're this is this is literally I didn't know that we were taking questions from listeners
是的，伍迪，我想我上次见到你……这算是一个很棒的……算不上什么大牌炫耀，但我上次见到你是在南法博诺（Bono）家举办的你的生日派对上。是这样吗？是的，老兄。我很高兴见到你。你知道，我喜欢《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）。我他妈太喜欢那部剧了。非常喜欢。而且……肖恩从来没看过。谢谢你，伍迪。肖恩，你没看过？你得去看，真的很好看。而且……叫什么来q？是一个叫……的组合，《发展受阻》，是亚特兰大的一支嘻哈乐队。你从窗户爬进来向你的……十几岁女朋友提出分手的那个场景……然后在第二天早晨，镜头切到你坐在那里吃鸡蛋，她说：“所以，你想跟我谈什么来着？”然后你说：“嗯……是什么？嗯……”然后你开始扯到那个……这件衣服值35美元。
It's from a random listener named justin t. Oh my god. So, uh, He he wants to know you're well known for your love and abuse. This is his worst My You're well known for your love and abuse of marijuana and other mind-altering substances Has work ever gotten in the way of your drug problem? And wait and follow-up question has your drug problem ever suffered as a result of your work Thank you caller Uh, justin t. That's a very, uh, insightful question. Uh
我经常这么做，顺便说一句，人们根本不知道我在干什么，然后我不得不去解释：这其实是一件3500美元的西装。那个场景让人困惑的地方在于，我出来时穿着她的睡衣，而她穿着我前一晚的衬衫。所以当我们开拍时我们意识到，我当时知道米奇（Mitch）会明白我想做什么，所以我开始贬低她的那件东西值多少钱，然后我开始抬高她身上穿的那件衣服的价值，因为她穿着我的衬衫。所以这简直就像是一个他妈的……然后米奇就像：我不敢相信这正在发生。但这对我来说太搞笑了，以至于我说：这件衣服值……然后我开始称赞她的那件衣服到底值多少钱。不管怎样，所以，伍迪，我们在博诺家，在为伍迪举办的大型生日派对上，他妻子也在，他女儿进来给他一个惊喜，许多人在场。那真是一个美妙的夜晚，然后……伍迪就像：哦，天哪……
As a matter of fact, uh, it does sometimes get in the way because like I'll I'll wake up I want to wake and bake. I'll be like, I can't wake me. I can't fucking wake and bake. Gotta wait till lunch. Yeah Thanks for asking that I can't believe that he had time to ask that write that question down Just because you know, he's usually just avoiding paparazzi. That's his number one Job like so the fact that he had the time to write that down. God bless Uh, no, but seriously, have you have what have you ever worked totally stoned like and it's like on cheers or anything Where you you're in a scene. You're like, I don't know where I am. Oh, yeah, I uh
然后他……我们开始笑着谈论那个场景。他说，他当时正在对我演那个场景，然后……晚宴上菜了，博诺走过来，他说：……他一直说：伙计们，晚宴上菜了。而伍迪……伍迪趴在地上演那个场景，最后我想他有点生气了，他说：……他就像：嘿，伍迪，好吧，你们可以在那边的桌子上演。我们就像：好吧，老兄，对不起。我们在演《发展受阻》的桥段呢，博诺。对我来说，这真的是……这也许是有史以来最伟大的喜剧时刻。充满智慧。
I was doing cheers and you know, we've been doing it for a while. Uh, so I don't know several years and and uh Uh, then I was I well, I thought we were done and I went up and I was smoking a joint with George went And uh, I hear over the intercom. What do you come down for your monologue and scene c and I'm like, oh Oh And I go down And it's like First take disaster second take worse, you know, takes me 10 takes and jimmy's like, what do you everything? Yeah, everything's fine jimmy everything's fine. Yeah, let's just try it again
那很好。我每次看还是会笑得流泪，我太爱了。我知道你那天经历了一段艰难的时期，因为你亲口告诉我，你能做到这一点真是太神奇了。哦，好吧，发生了什么？我当时在经历……那是我一生中最糟糕的日子之一。那是真的，我那天晚上确实跟你说过，那是极其……我当时在个人生活上经历了很多事情，而且找不到做头发用的定型慕斯了，因为那时候流行慕斯，对吧？哦……伍迪，说到……你引用的台词之类的事，就像我一开始说的，当你出现在这里时，我对《干杯酒吧》简直痴迷。我看过每一集，看过无数遍。而且你所取得的成就——我们之前稍微触及过这一点——你取得了许多电视演员没有做到的成就，那就是在之后成功开创了庞大的电影生涯。那是怎么发生的？你是主动去寻求的吗？这种转型是怎么发生的？
You know, so what would have been one simple, you know, it would just took like 10 fucking takes is a disaster So I learned that I can't you know all the things that you just take for granted just kind of go out the window I mean, you're probably uh will and jason. I'm sure uh have done cocaine while filming and you know, it just doesn't work Jason it's not fun. You spent I did it once and I spent my whole time trying to not look like I was all beaked up Yeah I remember we asked remember we asked seth rogan last year. We were like, man Do you ever shine you asked him like do you ever, you know, you ever gotten high before you work? And he was like, I've never not worked high
嗯，我的意思是，我想我们都在寻求它，对吧？是的，没错。但是，你知道，这真的是……我得到了和迈克尔·J·福克斯（Michael J. Fox）一起拍《好莱坞医生》（Doc Hollywood）的机会，那部电影反响很好。然后很幸运我打过篮球，我的经纪人后来告诉我：“你知道的，你以前总是想去拍戏，而你却在圣莫尼卡或别的地方打篮球，那些时间……得到了回报，因为有了《白人不能跳》（White Men Can't Jump）。”还有罗恩·谢尔顿（Ron Shelton），当时……我猜当时正值海湾战争一事发生，他听说我在……你知道的，抗议它。我说过类似“反恐战争就是恐怖主义”的话，这惹恼了很多人，并导致我失去了……你知道的，当时正在进行的很多利润丰厚的工作。没关系，但罗恩·谢尔顿非常喜欢它，很高兴我那样做了。斯科特·威勒（Scott Weller），顺便说一句，斯科特·威勒的替身就是罗恩·谢尔顿。哦，是的，是的，是的，异卵双胞胎。是的，是的。我们走吧，抱歉。
That's crazy. I know is that right? Yes. Yeah, he said that's what he said. I heard chris walken would would get high before doing shakespeare in the park Oh my god, it's how do you if you get lost how do you start improvising in iambic contaminant? Like how's that work? Wow I know that's crazy. How do you get that back? But I guess the old guys they used to all those old shakespeare actors those guys used to boost it up like over You know on the other side there in the uk those guys used to all get ahead Oh, yeah, but I feel like that might be different than weed like weed would for me
太疯狂了。我知道，是吗？是的。对，他说他就是这么说的。我听说克里斯·沃肯在公园演莎士比亚之前会嗨起来。天哪，如果你迷失了，你怎么开始用意步格进行即兴创作？这怎么行？哇，我知道这太疯狂了。你怎么能恢复过来？不过我想那些老家伙，他们以前所有那些老派莎士比亚演员，那些家伙以前会在那边英国那边加把劲，那些家伙以前都会嗨。哦，对，但我觉得这可能跟大麻不一样，因为大麻对我来说
It would be tough to remember my lines. I'd get too distracted probably I know that it's more about just like Going home and powering down for me. What about a gummy jason? Could you do it on a gummy? I might be able to just because you know, it goes into the blood system a little bit slower It doesn't punch you in the neck like a big fat hit off a doobie or a bomb, you know Yeah, woody. I think the last time I saw you. This is this is a great Not not much of a name drop, but the last time I saw you was at your birthday at bono's place In the south of france. Is that true? Yeah, dude. I I was so psyched to see you
要记住台词太难了。我可能会分心。我知道这更多是像回家关机一样。那来颗软糖怎么样，杰森？你吃软糖能演吗？我可能行，只是因为你知道，它进入血液循环系统慢一点。它不会像抽一口大麻烟或者抽大麻那样一下子重击你的脖子，你知道的。对，伍迪。我想我上次见你。这绝对不是在借大名炫耀，但我上次见你在博诺位于法国南部的家里参加你的生日派对。是真的吗？是的，老兄。我当时看到你太兴奋了
You know, I love arrested development. I fucking love that show Love it and um, shan's never seen it. Thank you. What if shon is not shon? You got to watch it. It's really good and uh, what's it called? It's a group called the rest of development. It's a hip hop band out of atlanta and That moment you had where you come in the window to break up with the you know, your teenage girlfriend is within and and then the next morning it cuts to you're sitting there eating your eggs And and and she says so what was it you wanted to talk to me about and you're like, uh, well
你知道，我太喜欢《发展受阻》了。我他妈太爱那部剧了。太喜欢了。而且，山姆从来没看过。谢谢。要是山姆不是山姆怎么办？你得看。真的很好。而且，叫什么来着？那是一个叫“发展受阻”的组合。是亚特兰大的一支嘻哈乐队。你进窗户去跟你那个十几岁的女朋友分手的那个场景，是在文内。然后第二天早上镜头切到你坐在那儿吃鸡蛋，然后她问：“那么，你想跟我谈什么来着？”然后你就说：“呃，那个……”
What is it? Uh, and then you get into that shit should the guy should the guy should $35 I do it all the time by the way and people have no idea what I'm doing and I'm like I have to then explain This is actually $3,500 suit Yeah What was confusing about that scene was that I come out and I'm wearing her I'm wearing her nightgown and she's wearing my shirt from the night before
是什么？呃，然后你开始扯那个蛋，“难道这西装……难道这西装……难道这西装要三千五百块？”我经常这么做，顺便说一句，人们根本不知道我在干什么，然后我不得不解释：“这其实是一件三千五百美元的西装。”对。那个场景让人困惑的是，我出来时穿着她的睡衣，而她穿着我前一晚的衬衫。
So we realized as as we were rolling I was kind of I knew that mitch was going to get what I was trying to do so that I started to Downgrade how much her thing was worth and then I started to upgrade what she was wearing because she was wearing my shirt So it was like such a fucking like and then mitch was like I can't believe this is happening But it was so funny to me that I'm like should the guy and then and I started sort of Complimenting how much hers is worth anyway, so woody so we're at bono's place in this big birthday party for woody and his Wife's there and his daughter comes in surprises him and bunch of people are there. It's really beautiful night and and um woody's like oh man
所以我们意识到，当我们在拍摄时，我差不多……我知道米奇会明白我想做什么，所以我开始贬低她的衣服值多少钱，然后我开始抬高她穿的衣服的价值，因为她穿着我的衬衫。所以这感觉太他妈像……然后米奇说：“我不敢相信这正在发生。”但这对我来说太搞笑了，我就说：“难道这西装……”然后我开始赞美她的衣服值多少钱。不管怎样，伍迪，所以我们在博诺的家里参加伍迪的大型生日派对，他妻子也在，他女儿进来给他惊喜，还有一堆人在场。这是一个非常美好的夜晚，然后伍迪说：“噢，天哪……”
And he and he started we start laughing about that scene He's like and he was doing the scene to me And then like dinner was served and bono comes over and he's like and he kept going guys dinner served and woody's What he's on the ground doing the scene and finally I think he got a little bit pissed and he was like And he was like hey woody well you guys can do it over there at the table. We're like, all right, man. Sorry We're doing scenes from a wrestling development bono It really to me it's it's one of the it's maybe the greatest comedic moment ever Intelligent
然后他开始……我们开始笑那个场景。他说，他当时在对我演那个场景。然后开始上晚宴了，博诺走过来，他一直在说：“伙计们，晚宴上桌了。”而伍迪……伍迪趴在地上演那个场景。最后我想他有点生气了，他就说：“嘿，伍迪，你们可以在那边的桌子上演。”我们就像，“好吧，老兄，对不起，我们在演《发展受阻》的场景呢，博诺。”真的，对我来说，这可能是最伟大的喜剧时刻之一。太聪明了。
That's nice. I still watch it and just I tear up laughing. I love it And I know you were going through a hard time that day because you told me so it's amazing. You were able to do that Oh, well, what happened? I was having a that was one of the worst days of my life. That's true I did tell you that that night it was a very I was going through a lot of stuff personally and couldn't find the moose for your hair Because it was moose back then right Oh Um woody uh speaking of uh lines you quote and stuff like I said at the beginning When you popped on here that I'm obsessed with shares. I I've seen every episode so many times
太好了。我现在看还是会笑出眼泪。我太喜欢了。我知道那天你经历了一段艰难的时期，因为你亲口告诉我，所以你能做到这一点真的很惊人。哦，好吧，发生什么了？我当时正经历……那是我一生中最糟糕的日子之一。确实如此。那天晚上我确实跟你说过，我当时在个人生活方面经历了很多事情，而且找不到做你发型用的慕斯了，因为那时候流行慕斯对吧？哦。呃，伍迪，说到你引用的台词之类的，就像我一开始当你出现在这里时说的，我对《干杯》痴迷不已。我看过每一集太多遍了。
And what you achieved we touched on this a little bit before you achieved with a lot of actors in tv Don't do which is kind of cultivate a massive gigantic film career afterwards What did that kind of happen to you? Did you seek it out? Like how well how did that transition happen for you? Well, I mean, I guess we're all seeking it out, right? Yeah, right, so but you know, it really was uh, I I got to do doc hollywood with mike Uh michael fox and then that did well Uh, and then it was lucky that I played basketball, you know, my agent told me later, you know All those times I was trying to get you and you were down playing hoops down in Santa Monica or whatever
而你所取得的成就——我们之前稍微聊过这点——你在电影界取得了很多电视演员做不到的成就，那就是之后成功开拓了庞大的电影事业。这算是怎么发生的？你是主动争取的吗？这种转变是怎么发生在你身上的？嗯，我的意思是，我想我们都在争取吧？对，对。所以，但你知道，这真的是……我得以和迈克尔·J·福克斯一起拍了《好莱坞医生》，那部戏反响不错。然后很幸运我打篮球，你知道的，我的经纪人后来告诉我，“你知道的，以前我总是想约你，而你却在圣莫尼卡或其他什么地方打篮球……”
You know Paid off because of white men can't jump and ron shelton who actually I call it. I guess it was bush war one at the time was going on and he had heard me You know protests it I said something like the war on terrorism is terrorism Which uh upset a lot of people and caused me to lose uh Uh, you know lucrative other things that were going on it didn't matter, but ron shelton very much liked it Was glad I did that scott weller scott weller's doppelganger ron shelton by the way Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah separate to birth. Yeah. Yeah. Here we go. Sorry
你知道，这得到了回报，因为有了《白人不能跳》。还有罗恩·谢尔顿——当时我管它叫……我想当时是第一次海湾战争正在进行，他听说我在抗议它，我说过类似“反恐战争就是恐怖主义”之类的话，这惹恼了许多人，导致我失去了很多正在进行的丰厚工作。这无所谓，但罗恩·谢尔顿非常喜欢，很高兴我这么做。顺便说一句，斯科特·韦勒，斯科特·韦勒的分身罗恩·谢尔顿。哦，对，对，对，对，异卵双胞胎。对，对。我们开始吧。抱歉。
Scott was scott weller's a buddy of ours lives in the south bay. He's a handyman He's got a great handyman business opening great handyman. Listen if something's broken, you need to fix you You're in the south bay. Yeah, you're in the south bay red man hat beach and something breaks you call scott weller and his handyman business through home hardware Let me write that down. So scott weller if i'm in there's a number at the bottom of your screen south bay california All right, so there's ron shelton. He puts you in white men can't jump that that is hugely successful Yeah, huge and then on from there, right? Yeah, I mean it hasn't stopped That's great. Was it has has there been has there been a slow period that that was not by design?
Scott 是 Scott Weller，我们的一个好朋友，住在南湾。他是个杂工，他开了一家很棒的杂工业务，非常棒的杂工。听着，如果有什么东西坏了，你需要修理，你在南湾。对，你在南湾雷曼海滩，如果有什么东西坏了，你就找 Scott Weller 和他在 Home Hardware 的杂工业务，让我把它记下来。所以，Scott Weller 如果我在，你屏幕底部有一个号码，南湾，加利福尼亚。好的，那是朗·谢尔顿。他让你出演了《白人不能跳》，那是巨大的成功。是的，巨大成功。从那以后，对吧？是的，我的意思是它一直没停过。太棒了。曾经有过，有过低谷期吗，那不是刻意安排的？
Has it slowed down for you? There was After people versus larry flint Um, so brilliant things uh kind of Because that was disappointing to uh, sony Even though a lot of people maybe watched it after you know, but at the time they didn't and and also it was really Gloria steinham had gone on a Went from one place to another all over the country telling people not to see it. Uh, this is our pray op-ed which uh was devastating um and uh
你的工作放缓了吗？在《性书大亨》之后，有些……真是不错的东西，有点……因为这对索尼来说挺令人失望的，尽管可能很多人后来才看，你知道，但当时他们没看，而且还有……格洛丽亚·斯泰纳姆到处跑，从一个地方到另一个地方，在全国各地告诉人们不要去看。呃，这是我们的祈祷专栏文章，这具有毁灭性的打击，呃，而且……
Anyway, so people would tell me look i'd like to watch it, but uh, you know, my wife won't let me see it Yeah, so that that was a real uh, isn't that weird things kind of went down after that and that was also when I decided Uh, I'm gonna just stop working for a while. So I did for five years. I weren't you nominated for that Yeah, yeah, you were nominated for an oscar and things went down after that Wait, wait, wait, wait a second. Let me show you cut them up. So for five years. What are you five years? You basically? Yeah, from like around 97 to 02 Other than I did one thing, uh, which i'm glad I did uh Uh for ron Howard the ed tv, you know with oh, yeah, which is where I got to know matthew
总之，人们会告诉我，听着，我很想看，但是，你知道，我妻子不让我看。所以，那真是个真正的……在那之后事情不是变得有点走下坡路了吗？这也是我决定，呃，我要停工一段时间的时候。所以我歇了五年。你不是凭那个获得提名了吗？对，对，你获得了奥斯卡提名，在那之后事情就走下坡路了。等等，等等，等等，等一下。让我打断一下。所以五年。什么五年？你基本上？对，大概从97年到02年。除了我做了一件事，呃，我很高兴我做了，呃，为了朗·霍华德的《艾德·TV》，你知道的，哦，对了，那是我认识马修的地方。
That's great. Uh, and then I did one other little thing Other than that. Yeah. Hey, I didn't work. Oh, and I did theater I was like, I want to get in touch with my roots, you know So like from around 97 to 2002 Yeah, I I didn't do anything and probably, you know, the phone wasn't ringing off the wall or anything during that time Yeah, and then when I started when I came back to work again I was like, you know, I'm not expecting a tick or tape parade or anything, but I thought there'd be no There was nothing it was completely. I was completely forgotten and I was just
太棒了。呃，然后我又做了一件小事。除此之外。是的。嘿，我没工作。哦，我演了戏剧。我当时想，我想重新接触我的根基，你知道的。所以大概从97年到2002年，是的，我什么也没做，可能，你知道的，那段时间电话也没怎么响过什么的。然后当我开始，当我重新开始工作时，我心想，你知道的，我并不期待什么阅兵式或者别的什么，但我以为会有……什么都没有。完全没有。我完全被遗忘了，我当时只是……
Trying desperately to get anything and anyway, it was a slow. What was the first big thing that restarted it? Well, I did this movie, um after the sunset of Pierce Brosnan and Salma Hayek, uh, Brett Ratner And uh, even though it didn't do that well, I think it started, you know, just kicking things off You know how it goes guys, you know, yeah, it's uh, it's up and down. Yeah Well, I'm sure but you know, it's great what he's I bet that people are like Love to take credit of going like that they rediscovered you like, yeah, you know, what are you?
拼命地想得到任何工作，不管怎样，那是一段低谷。重新开始的第一个重大契机是什么？嗯，我拍了这部电影，嗯，皮尔斯·布鲁斯南和萨尔玛·海耶克的《日落之后》，布莱特·拉特纳导演的。而且，尽管它表现不是那么好，但我认为它开始，你知道的，只是让事情重新运转起来。你知道那是怎么回事，伙计们，你知道的，是的，这是……这是起起落落。是的。好吧，我确信，但你知道，这很棒，他……我敢打赌人们会喜欢邀功，就好像他们重新发现了你一样，就像，是的，你知道，你算什么？
Yeah, would he be really great like you haven't changed you've been great since you started And it's like everything else takes you know It's so funny perspective is fucking crazy because you do that people versus Larry flint and as Sean said you were awesome Obviously you were nominated. You were awesome. My recollection seeing that film in the theater was How great it was and how great you were and if you were to ask me like boy if you were to say like what? You know, uh, uh, you know, how's Woody Harrell? Oh, he's great man. Yeah, he just did that people versus Larry flint He was incredible. He was nominated. He's a great actor and he's so good and he's so diverse and he can do kind of anything And when the reality of your perspective is totally different, but it's so fucking crazy and it's so subjective, right?
是的，真的很棒，就像你没变一样，你从一开始就很棒。就像其他所有事情一样，你知道的。太搞笑了，这种视角真是太疯狂了，因为你拍了《性书大亨》，正如肖恩所说，你太棒了，显然你获得了提名。你太棒了。我当时在电影院看那部电影的记忆是，它有多棒，你有多棒。如果你问我，比如，天哪，如果你说，你知道，呃，呃，你知道，伍迪·哈里森怎么样？哦，他太棒了，伙计。是的，他刚拍了那部《性书大亨》，他太不可思议了。他获得了提名。他是个伟大的演员，他那么优秀，戏路那么广，他几乎能胜任任何角色。而现实中你的视角完全不同，但这真是太疯狂了，而且太主观了，对吧？
I mean, that's bizarre. It's gig to gig still. Yeah, always. Yeah, always. It's crazy always. Um, Jason's about to take five years off He didn't know it. Yeah. Oh, no Yeah, yeah, I just talked to showbiz. They said you're taking five years And was that an alert that you got or? We'll be right back And now back to the show Let me switch for a second and two. I know that you've um You've got some uh, some beliefs and some passions in sort of like a lot of sort of our environmental stuff
我的意思是，这太离奇了。现在仍然是一场演出接一场演出。是的，一直都是。是的，一直都是。总是这么疯狂。嗯，杰森马上要休息五年了。他自己都不知道。是的。哦，不。是的，是的，我刚和娱乐圈的人聊过，他们说你要休息五年。那是你收到的通知还是？我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。让我暂时换个话题。我知道你，呃，你有一些，呃，一些信仰和热情，比如说像我们的很多环保方面的事情。
And I do as well and and if you're like me sometimes you get a little bit frustrated with the slow pace of things How do you manage your your happiness or lack of based on the progression or lack of on sort of tackling some of these things that are Really kind of existential. We don't want to get into politics too much. We don't like to on this show that much But I'm just wondering if you got a tip for me. Is it about not watching the news or not reading the paper to see the slow pace of things Or is it the opposite? How do you manage your your frustration? Well, I mean, I I do feel like the The the world's kind of going to hell in a handbasket and uh, yeah, I feel like sometimes Uh, you know with the global warming and that you see the effect of it even here where it's unnaturally warm Although it's fucking freezing balls here. They for them. They're it's unnatural warm
我也有同感。如果你和我一样，有时你会对事情的进展缓慢感到有点沮丧。你是如何管理你的快乐或不快乐的，基于解决其中一些真正具有存在主义意义的事情的进展或缺乏进展？我们不想过多谈论政治。在这个节目里我们不太喜欢这样。但我只是想知道你有没有什么建议给我？是不看新闻还是不读报纸来了解事情的进展缓慢？还是相反？你如何控制你的沮丧情绪？好吧，我的意思是，我确实觉得世界有点像在向混乱滑落，呃，是的，我觉得有时，你知道，随着全球变暖，你甚至在这里也能看到它的影响，这里异常温暖，尽管这里冷得要命。对他们来说，这里异常温暖。
and uh You know, you see it everywhere. You see the signs of it. It's not a mystery that the That the global warming is having a devastating impact and uh, all these predictions that were made, you know 30 years ago 40 years ago are coming true and then, you know People say well, you know Well, things are moving foot. Well, I I don't know. I mean, it seems like the big oil companies and all the giant freaking You know industries that have raped mother earth on a daily basis for
而且，你知道的，你到处都能看到。你看到了它的迹象。全球变暖正在产生毁灭性的影响，这不是什么秘密，呃，所有这些在30年前、40年前做出的预测都正在成为现实，然后，你知道的，人们会说，好吧，你知道的，事情正在取得进展。好吧，我不知道。我的意思是，看起来那些大石油公司和所有那些每天都在蹂躏地球的庞然大物般的，你知道的，各个行业……
They forever. Yeah, it seems like they just keep doing business as usual and and I don't see Change is happening. Um, so how do you manage your frustration with that? I don't know. I it really I think about it every day. I I know I really I was gonna say Jason. I was gonna say one of the things and woody you can speak to this You know, I remember when we did semi pro 10 12 years ago with will ferrell And you had that your bus, which I think you still have that you use as your trailer And what do you have this bus that run that runs on?
永远都在。是的，看起来它们只是在照常营业，我没有看到改变正在发生。所以，你如何应对由此产生的沮丧情绪？我不知道。我真的，我每天都在想这件事。我知道我真的……我正要说，杰森。我正要说的一件事是，伍迪，你可以谈谈这个。你知道，我记得10、12年前我们和威尔·法瑞尔一起拍《半职业选手》的时候。你有那辆巴士，我想你现在还留着，你把它当成你的房车。伍迪，你这辆巴士是用什么驱动的？
vegetable oil biodiesel biodiesel He's got like a cork floor. It's got all this stuff. It's like renewable You've been doing it. You've been kind of walking the walk for a long time and it's like, yeah The first, you know, the thing that you can do is everybody could do it if everybody thought like that more It's it's about changing once again changing our perception and changing how we approach stuff, right? Yeah, I mean, I think it really has to do with how we How we feed ourselves, uh, you know How we feed ourselves
植物油，生物柴油，生物柴油。他有类似软木的地板。它有所有这些东西。它是可再生的。你一直在这么做。你长期以来一直在付诸行动，就像，是的，首先，你知道的，你能做的事情就是每个人都可以这样做，如果每个人都更多地这样想的话。这又是关于改变，改变我们的认知，改变我们处理事情的方式，对吧？是的，我的意思是，我认为这真的与我们如何……我们如何滋养自己有关，呃，你知道的，我们在行星层面上如何滋养自己，你知道的，我们的燃料是什么，还有我们的个人燃料是什么，我认为这也是……
Planetarily, you know, what our fuel is and also what our personal fuel is. I think is also Incredibly important What would they say and I was watching the news the other day that that growing cows for for food is 2 thirds of the of the world's pollution Is that right or what it takes to to farm cows? Is that right? Or is it one third something like that? I think that it's a huge thing. Uh, the the methane generated from Cows and what is that? Like from their from their poop. Is that is that the methane? Yeah, I think it's from uh, just there
极其重要。他们会怎么说？我前几天看新闻说，为了食物而养牛占了世界污染的三分之二？是这样吗，还是养牛需要付出什么？是这样吗？还是三分之一左右？我认为这是一件大事。牛产生的甲烷，那是什么？比如来自它们的粪便？甲烷是那样的吗？是的，我想是来自它们的……
Really? Yeah, yeah, meanwhile throw it on your flowers and it's okay cow crap is killing our planet. Is that right? It's their farts. It's the farts Cow farts the farts You know farting there was a time when farting was really funny. Yeah, no now it's killing. That's killing us killing us Uh, what do you look what type of stuff are you eating nowadays? Are you full? Are you a full vegan? Oh, yeah. Well, I've been a vegan for uh, since 1990 January one but yeah
真的吗？是的，是的。与此同时，把它倒在你的花上，这就没问题了。牛粪正在杀死我们的地球。是这样吗？是它们的屁。是屁。牛屁，屁。你知道，放屁，曾几何时，放屁是一件很好笑的事。是的，不，现在它正在致命。这正在杀死我们，杀死我们。呃，伍迪，看看你，你现在吃什么类型的食物？你是吗？你是全素食主义者吗？哦，是的。嗯，我从1990年1月1日起就是个素食主义者，但是，是的……
I I'm mostly raw. I try to eat mostly raw. You know, you gotta like a salad if you're eating mostly raw. So yeah, I love salad I just uh, you know, I want to eat as clean as possible. Uh, you know to compensate for my other Uh Issues pollutions. Uh-huh. Yeah Now how do you find it difficult to get raw clean food as you travel around the world? Is I mean, I imagine it's got to be a lot easier in the major cities But when you're gone location in different parts you have to bring food with you
我基本上吃生食。我尽量主要吃生食。你知道，如果你主要吃生食，你得喜欢沙拉。所以，是的，我喜欢沙拉。我只是，你知道的，我想吃得尽可能干净。呃，你知道的，为了弥补我的其他，呃，问题，污染。嗯哼。是的。现在，当你环游世界时，你会觉得买到生的、干净的食物很难吗？我的意思是，我想在大城市里一定容易得多，但当你在不同地方的外景地时，你必须随身携带食物吗？
Or you have like a a cook or something like that. Yeah, I have a chef here. Yeah, they miss Cole. She's great. Yeah Yeah, uh, but yeah, I know I know it's a little bit of a privileged lifestyle guys. I guess it is No, no, but I I mean, you have to apologize to us. Yeah, I know you're the privileged, of course Yeah, I don't know what now. Let me ask you this. Do you know when you do go city to city? How do you get your weed? Do you have connects in every city? That's what I need to know because it's legal everywhere, isn't it? Most places it's legal, you know Look, I mean, I used to carry it with me, which was a stupid move
还是你有厨师之类的？是的，我这里有一个厨师。是的，她叫米斯考。她很好。是的。呃，但，是的，我知道，我知道这稍微有点特权阶级的生活方式，伙计们。我想是的。不，不，我的意思是，你不必向我们道歉。是的，我知道你是特权阶级，当然。是的，我不知道现在。让我问你这个。你知道，当你从一个城市到另一个城市时，你是如何弄到大麻的？你在每个城市都有人脉吗？这正是我需要知道的，因为它到处都是合法的，不是吗？在大多数地方都是合法的，你知道的。听着，我的意思是，我过去常常随身携带它，这是一个愚蠢的举动。
but And then I realized at one point. Oh my god, it's everywhere You know, now is it is it legal up in Canada? Yeah, it's legal. Oh, there you go. So you got you just go down to the store You just pick up some milk and do that. Yeah, I remember when you had me you gave me a taste of your spirulina or something like that Yeah, that stuff's good thing. I'm just fucking threw up More than that, that's the analogy. It gives you nice nice energy. Yeah, it's good for you. It's really good for you. Mix it up with stuff Woody before I forget uh freak brothers. It's a new cartoon you're in with John Goodman, Tiffany Haddish What else is in it? Pete Davidson is in it. That's good. That's crazy. It looks great
但是……然后我在某个时刻意识到，哦，天哪，它无处不在。你知道，现在，它在加拿大合法吗？是的，合法。哦，那就对了。所以你只需要去商店，你只要买点牛奶，然后就这样。是的，我记得你让我尝过你的螺旋藻什么的。是的，那东西挺好。谢天谢地我刚吐了。比那更好，那是类比。它给你很好很好的能量。 yeah，对你有好处。真的对你有好处。把它和别的东西混在一起。伍迪，在我忘记之前，呃，《怪胎兄弟》，这是你和约翰·古德曼、蒂凡尼·哈迪斯一起出演的新动画片。里面还有谁？皮特·戴维森也在里面。这太棒了。这太疯狂了。看起来很棒。
You and John Goodman perfect. You I love that because you guys are both so soft. What cartoon is that? What's it on? It's called freak brothers. What is on to to be right fabulous furry freak brothers Uh, yeah, too. It's on to be to be Do I have to be Hey, can we get that as a as an audio bite uh guys rob just pegged that just remember that do I have to be That's their tagline. Do I need to go on hypochondria actor to figure out if I've got to be or no I want to get this on a clip so I can be like Fred on Howard Stern where I can just keep me clicking. Do I have to be How does one get to be oh my god, keep going
你和约翰·古德曼，绝配。我喜欢这个，因为你们俩都太温和了。那是部什么动画片？它在什么平台上播？它叫《怪胎兄弟》。在哪个平台上播？To-Bi？神话般的毛茸茸的怪胎兄弟。呃，是的，2。它在To-Bi上。To-Bi。我必须To-Bi吗？嘿，我们能把这个做成一个音频片段吗？伙计们，罗布刚刚记下了，只要记住那个。我必须To-Bi吗？那是他们的标语。我需要去“恐病演员”看看我是不是必须To-Bi，还是不用？我想把这个弄成一个剪辑，这样我就可以像霍华德·斯特恩节目里的弗雷德一样，一直点。我必须To-Bi吗？人怎么才能To-Bi？哦，天哪，继续。
You're asking me Yeah, man, you're the spokesman. He doesn't know what he said to be with a question mark. I'm Just ask one of your assistants to download it for you. Yeah, man He says wait, what do you go back? I want to talk about Matthew McConaughey. I didn't know you guys were so close You guys are good buds, right? Yeah, yeah speaking of you and Matthew Are you are you aware of the of what you have done for this industry with what you guys did with true detective? Yeah, and in making the the limited series a cool. Yeah the television space for like when Two big shot film actors like you guys come on and like I would equate it to when Fincher did house of cards on Netflix
你在问我吗？是的，老兄，你是代言人。他不知道他说了“带有问号的To-Bi”。我只是让你的一个助手帮你下载。是的，老兄。他说，等等，伍迪，回去吧。我想谈谈马修·麦康纳。我不知道你们关系这么好。你们是好哥们儿，对吧？是的，说到你和马修，你知道你们俩和《真探》一起为这个行业做出了什么贡献吗？是的，把限定剧变成了一种很酷的东西。是的，电视领域，当像你们俩这样的大牌电影演员加入时，我会把它比作芬奇在网飞上制作《纸牌屋》的时候。
The combination of those two things. I think well, it's just expanded so much more So many more places for everyone to work Well, it made it feel okay and not like because there used to always be that thing of like it wasn't cool to do And then you guys came in film. I don't do tv on apologetically. You guys fucking kill it. God. I love that What are you and Matthew and that thing was so good. Oh, thank you guys. It's such a great job. Yeah Yeah, it was so fucking good. And then it's just like made it okay for everybody to do that. Like that was huge Did you love doing that project? Yeah Uh, I mean, you know, there were times I would
这两者的结合，我认为，好吧，它只是扩展得更多了，有更多的地方可以让每个人工作。好吧，它让人觉得没问题，不再像以前那样，因为以前总有一种说法，觉得演电视剧不酷，然后你们进来了，电影界人士说我不演电视剧，毫无歉意。你们这群混蛋太厉害了。天哪，我太喜欢这个了。你和马修，那部戏太棒了。哦，谢谢你们，伙计们。干得太出色了。是的，是的，它太他妈棒了。然后它就像是让所有人都可以这样做变得没问题了。这太棒了。你喜欢做那个项目吗？是的。我的意思是，你知道，有时我……
I would get kind of angry with uh, Matthew, you know, I had one of my best buddies So it felt weird, but he was in character in that fucking character Just made me want to fucking slap him. I was He's so good, you know, but he didn't stay in character and you know, not after work But while we were at work, you know, it wasn't like hey buddy, you know, none of that Uh, so that was a little but anyway, it turned out good. Yeah Did you have a sense while you were doing it? How good it was and what the style of it was or did Carrie Foucahnaga sort of not really was it was it not that
我会对马修有点生气，你知道，我最好的哥们儿之一，所以感觉很怪，但他当时完全沉浸在那个混蛋角色里。那个角色真让我只想狠狠地扇他一巴掌。我当时……他太棒了，你知道的，但他并没有一直保持角色状态，你知道的，不是下班后，而是在我们工作的时候，可不是什么“嘿，老朋友”之类的，完全没有。所以那有点……不管怎样，结果很不错。是的。你在拍的时候有一种感觉吗，知道它有多棒以及它的风格是什么样的，还是说卡瑞·福永并没有真正……是不是没那么清晰，你真的得看很多回放才能领会到，还是说你在拍的时候就能看出来？
Clear you had to really watch a lot of play back to get a sense of it or could you tell while you were shooting it? Uh, I mean, I thought it was going to be good, but you know, it's rare You find a thing like hit the zeitgeist like that. That that's extreme. I mean you have it already, you know, you got ozark You got the uh rested development You know, you you're mr. Zeitgeist Jason, but for the rest of us, it's a very it's a very Great So, yeah, it was wild. I had no idea that it would be, you know, that kind of thing And I thought it did turn out really good. So good. Yeah, fantastic. You're so great now
呃，我的意思是，我以为它会很不错，但你知道的，像这样引起时代精神共鸣的事情很少见。太极端了。我的意思是，你已经有了，你知道的，你有《黑钱胜地》，你有《发展受阻》，你知道的，你就是时代精神先生，杰森。但对我们其他人来说，这是一个非常……非常棒的……所以，是的，这太疯狂了。我不知道它会变成那种东西，而且我认为它确实结果非常棒。太棒了。是的，太 fantastique 了。你现在太棒了。
So, um, what about, um, I want to know because these guys hate it hate this but I'm a huge huge huge star wars freak and when you were in solo, I was like, oh my god, that's so cool and uh, were you a fan of it before or were you just like I'd say what he's pretty close to art to today's new Harrison Ford. I would I would anoint him the new Harrison Ford Right, if you were gonna cast on solo today, I'd put what he had. That's a big thing to say. That's a big thing to say. Yeah Yeah, I'm sorry. Go ahead. Wow. Thank you. Do I have to be? It's from that guy that's where your compliment came from. No, I want to know I want to know if you were a fan of the star wars franchise over you
所以，呃，关于，呃，我想知道，因为这些家伙讨厌这个，讨厌这个，但我是一个超级超级超级的《星球大战》迷，当你出演《游侠索罗》时，我当时想，哦，天哪，太酷了。呃，你以前就是它的粉丝，还是只是觉得……我可以说伍迪相当接近今天的年轻哈里森·福特。我会封他为新的哈里森·福特，对吧？如果你今天要为主演《游侠索罗》选角，我会让伍迪上。这可真是个大评价。这可真是个大评价。是的。对不起，请继续。哇。谢谢。我必须To-Bi吗？就是那个家伙，你的赞美就是从那来的。不，我想知道，我想知道你是不是《星球大战》系列的粉丝，还是说你……
Kind of a fan and not just was like, oh, I could learn to like this or whatever No, I was kind of a fan You know, I wasn't like a mega fan because these fans out here of that the star wars stuff I mean, those guys are pretty serious. So I would be I don't think it's a fair to call myself That kind of fan, but I you know, I liked it, of course Wasn't there a director swap in the middle there and you had to redo a bunch of stuff with Ron Ron Howard. Yeah, that was a long long shoot. I'll bet It was it was like
算是粉丝，而不只是觉得，哦，我可以学会喜欢这个之类的？不，我算是个粉丝。你知道的，我不是那种超级粉丝，因为这些《星球大战》的粉丝，我的意思是，那些家伙相当认真。所以我想我把自己称为那种粉丝是不公平的，但我，你知道的，我喜欢它，当然。中间不是换过导演吗，你不得不和朗·霍华德一起重拍了很多东西？朗·霍华德。是的，那是一次漫长漫长的拍摄，我敢说。它大概……
Maybe nine nine ten months total by the time we were done Yeah, at least nine months retooling it. How did you like living in England that long? Yeah, and I'd been there on a project just before so I was in in london for a year Uh, which you know, I like london, but that was a year. What do you did that thing? Didn't didn't you do a live tv thing? Was that what you were doing? That's what I did before. Yeah, it was cool What was that deal? Yeah, it was uh, it's called uh lost in london. I wrote it and directed it and uh Uh, yeah, it was it went live in the theaters, which was cool. That had never happened. Oh, wow I remember that. Yeah, how did you like doing that? Was it more stress than it was worth or was it?
等我们完成的时候，总共大概有九个月、九个月到十个月吧。是的，至少九个月在重新调整。你在英格兰待了那么久感觉怎么样？是的，我之前在一个项目上刚去过那里，所以我在伦敦待了一年，你知道的，我喜欢伦敦，但那是一年。伍迪，你做了那件事？你不是做了一个直播电视节目吗？你当时在做那个吗？那就是我之前做的。是的，很酷。那是什么情况？是的，呃，它叫《伦敦失落》。我编剧并导演的，呃，是的，它在电影院进行直播，这很酷。以前从没有过这种事。哦，哇。我记得那个。是的。你觉得做那个怎么样？压力是不是比付出的还要大，还是？
It's super exciting. Well, yeah, you know, it was like theater, but like on a you know on another scale with 500 extras and 500 crew and You know It was it was wild the stress nearly nearly killed me I got to say I I don't know when I've ever been that fucking stress All kinds of shit the sound wouldn't work. I gotta see that and the and the and the The the the we did a run through the night before the video goes out for 45 minutes the the feed I mean, it's like so this was basically a live movie that you were beaming into movie theaters. Yeah. Yeah
超级刺激。好吧，是的，你知道，这就像戏剧，但在另一个规模上，有500名临时演员和500名剧组人员，你知道的。这太疯狂了。压力差点……差点把我杀死。我得说，我不知道我什么时候曾经承受过那么大的压力。各种破事，声音无法工作。我得看看那个，而且，而且，而且……我们在视频播出的前一天晚上进行了45分钟的彩排，信号……我的意思是，这基本上是一部你直接投射到电影院的直播电影。是的。是的。
Wow, where did that idea come from that sounds like a Total like a like a like masochistic It was masochistic. Well, I I had already decided I wanted to do it in a one or you know, so it was a single camera and uh I'd already decided and then someone else mentioned a buddy of mine Tom cartesotus mentioned Hey, why don't you just beam it right into the theater while you what?
哇，那个主意是从哪来的？听起来完全像是一个……完全就像是一个有虐待狂倾向的……这确实有虐待狂倾向。好吧，我早就决定我想用一个长镜头来拍，你知道的，所以这是一个单机位，呃，我早就决定了，然后其他人提到了，我的一个朋友汤姆·卡特索蒂斯提到，“嘿，为什么不一边直播，一边直接把它投射到电影院里呢？什么？”
That's a crazy idea and then started finding out You know went to different people to see if it could be done and everybody was like, well, no, I it can't be done And then finally someone said yes So did that did that kill the the the desire to direct anything else after that? Or did you go on and direct other stuff? Well, I would like to direct something else But I don't want to do it in a one or or live. I'd rather have multiple tapes There's a million things I would have done different honestly But it turned out pretty good. Yeah, and Owen Wilson's in it and Willie Nelson. It's good. I'd love to see that
这真是一个疯狂的主意，然后开始四处打听，你知道的，去找不同的人看这是否可行，每个人都说，“嗯，不，这行不通。”然后终于有人说行。所以，在那之后，这是否扼杀了你再去导演其他东西的愿望？还是你继续去导演其他的东西？嗯，我愿意导演其他东西，但我不想用一个长镜头或直播来拍。我宁愿有多个素材带。老实说，有一百万件事我本可以做得不同，但结果相当不错。是的，欧文·威尔逊在里面，还有威利·纳尔逊。很好。我很想看看那个。
I know how cool is that? I think you can find it on to be or something. Jason. Do you have to be under it? Do I have to be? Oh my god, it's my favorite Woody we we've taken a lot of your time today I really appreciate you being here and I know you're stuck in Winnipeg working So please don't say stuck in Winnipeg to all our friends in Winnipeg. We love you. We especially my family Woody, I'm going to send you some people you got to go see Oh, I'm sure he's going to love that. Oh, great. Obligate him to a couple of at-home dinners Do they cook raw? I mean, come on, Will
我知道，多酷啊！我想你可以在To-Bi上找到它或者别的什么。杰森，你非要To-Bi吗？我必须To-Bi吗？哦，天哪，这是我最喜欢的。伍迪，今天我们占用了你很多时间。非常感谢你来到这里，我知道你被困在温尼伯工作。所以请不要对我们在温尼伯的所有朋友说“困在温尼伯”。我们爱你，尤其是我的家人。伍迪，我要给你介绍一些人，你一定要去见见。哦，我敢肯定他会喜欢那个的。哦，太棒了。强迫他去吃几次家庭晚餐。他们会做生食吗？拜托，威尔。
Do they cook raw? They got to uncook it Well, I'd uh, sure love to see you in person when you're done up there in Canada And maybe while you're switching planes down here on your way to Maui, just let us know we'll meet you down at LAX I would love that. Woody, come to town and come to have to hang out with us, man. Come on, Woody I would love it. Do you guys ever hang out with each other or are you just always Last night, always. Just last night No, last night, every night and Wednesday night and Thursday every night. These are the only people we see live
他们会做生食吗？他们得把它弄回生的。好吧，你在加拿大那边的事情忙完后，我真的很想亲自见到你。也许当你从这里转机去毛伊岛的路上时，告诉我们一声，我们在洛杉矶国际机场接你。我求之不得。伍迪，来城里和我们一起玩吧，老兄。来吧，伍迪。我很乐意。你们俩平时会一起出去玩吗，还是你们总是……昨晚，总是。昨晚刚见过。不，昨晚，每天晚上，还有周三晚上，周四，每天晚上。这些人是我们唯一活生生见到的人。
Yeah, it fit right in. Come on. It fit right in. Come on in, man Yeah, well, this has really been a pleasure. I gotta say, you know, I hate doing interviews, but this was a fucking fun one Thank you so much guys for making it so fun. I can't remember one question. We asked you I know, but wow, I'm glad you did it. We find we love you, Woody. You're the best. Yeah, I love you pal Thanks, Will. Love you too, man. Sean, love you, brother Jason. What a pleasure. Love you pal And guys, uh, see you next time. See you at LAS. See you next time, Woody Okay, buddy. All right. Okay, pal. Bye, buddy. See you, pal I
是的，完全合拍。来吧。进来吧，老兄。是的，这真的是一次愉快的经历。我必须说，你知道，我讨厌做采访，但这绝对是一个有趣的采访。非常感谢你们让它变得这么有趣。我不记得我们问过你什么问题了。我知道，但哇，我很高兴你来了。我们发现，我们爱你，伍迪。你是最棒的。是的，我也爱你，老朋友。谢谢，威尔。我也爱你，老兄。肖恩，爱你，兄弟。杰森，真是荣幸。爱你，老朋友。伙计们，呃，下次见。洛杉矶国际机场见。下次见，伍迪。好的，老朋友。好吧。好的，老朋友。再见，老朋友。我……
Love Woody. Who doesn't he's the best. He's a great dude. I know It's terrible that he lives all the way out there in Maui. Why doesn't he uh, I didn't know he lived there If we pitch in and get let's pitch in and get him a small studio apartment in Los Angeles So he could spend more time in LA and more time with us Yeah, we'll get him a place like like in north Hollywood just like a nice little unassuming so it won't cost us 500 square feet Let's go. By the way, let's get wise. Let's go visit him in Maui Maui, what are we doing? That sounds smarter. That sounds better. It will go, uh I do feel like
我爱伍迪。谁不爱呢？他是最棒的。他是个绝佳的家伙。我知道，他居然住在那么远的毛伊岛，太糟糕了。他为什么不……我不知道他住在那里。如果我们凑钱给他买个洛杉矶的小单身公寓呢，这样他就能在洛杉矶多待点时间，也能多和我们在一起。对，我们给他找个地方，就像在好莱坞北部那样，一个nice的小地方，不显山露水的那种，所以花不了多少钱，500平方英尺。走吧。顺便说一句，我们要聪明点，去毛伊岛看他。毛伊岛？我们在干什么？听起来更聪明。听起来更好。我们会去……
We should be seeing more of him and we'll never do what we see him We see him on the uh, on the big screen on the tv and the big and to be don't forget. Oh my god. Do you Do I to be do you have to I would love to to be I know you it is not enough snow out there to By the way, this is turn into an ad for to be. I know lucky. What it what is it? But how would you pronounce? How do you pronounce that I am? Oh, that's quick. Let's get right to it Yeah, do you not want to are you done? You don't want to talk to me. He was your guest I think it's not it's not spelt to you be right It's it's spelt it's spelt if you were to say it like it's spelt sean. What would it sound like to?
我确实觉得我们应该多见见他，但我们永远不会像……我们在大屏幕上、电视上见到他，还有大屏幕上……还有To-Bi，别忘了。哦，天哪。你，我，To-Bi，你必须……我很想To-Bi。我知道，外面雪下得还不够大，不能……顺便说一句，这变成了一个To-Bi的广告。我知道，真幸运。它是什么？但是你怎么发音？你怎么发音那个……我是……哦，太快了。我们直接开始吧。是的，你不想……你受够了吗？你不想跟我说话吗？他可是你的客串嘉宾。我觉得它拼写不是T-O-B-Y，对吧？它是拼写……它是拼写，如果你按它的拼写读出来的话，肖恩，它听起来会是什么样？To-。
You Smartless is 100 organic and artisanly handcrafted by rob armjurf benet barbaco and michael grand terry Smart less Do I have to be our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts Or you can listen to it right now early on amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to wonderie plus in apple podcasts or the wonderie app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless 是由 Rob Armjuref、Benet Barbaco 和 Michael Grand Terry 以 100% 有机和手工方式制作的。Smart Less。我必须To-Bi吗？我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在 Amazon Music 上提前收听，或者通过订阅 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondery Plus 或 Wondery App 提前收听且无广告。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。